bien bonjour à toutes et à tous madame
la ministre chers collègues la
commission des affaires économiques
auditionne cet après-midi madame AGS
panirunaché ministre de la transition
énergétique madame la ministre je vous
remercie d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation après une audition le 13
septembre 2022 dans le cadre d'un cycle
nous permettant d'entendre tous les
ministres qui interviennent dans le
champ de compétenence de la commission
les affaires économiques puis une
audition le 12 juillet dernier avec
Bruno lire sur le financement des
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires c'est donc
la troisième fois que vous vous
présentez devant nous hors examen d'un
texte législatif encore une fois
bienvenue la présente réunion s'imposé
du fait de la très riche actualité
concernant la fixation des prix de
l'électricité le 17 octobre vous-même et
les autres ministres européens de
l'énergie êtes parvenu à un accord très
attendu sur la réforme du marché
européen de l'électricité cette réforme
était devenue indispensable du fait de
la volatilité des prix autorisé par les
mécanismes actuels mais il s'agit d'un
sujet très sensible pour nos partenaires
allemands j'ai d'ailleurs pu le mesurer
fin septembre lorsque j'ai conduit une
délégation de députés de notre
commission pour des réunions à Berlin au
Bundestag avec la commission de
l'économie et la Commission de la
protection du climat et de l'énergie
nous attendons donc que vous nous
précisiez les contours de cet accord
européen et que vous nous fassiez part
des étapes suivantes notamment des
négociations en cours au sein du
Parlement européen par ailleurs
mi-novembre le gouvernement a dévoilé en
accord avec EDF les grandes ligne du
nouveau mécanisme de régulation des prix
de l'électricité d'origine nucléaire qui
doit donc succéder à laarè
pourriez-vous nous expliquer
l'articulation entre l'accord européen
et ce nouveau mécanisme national et nous
détailler les modalités de mise en œuvre
de ce derni vous savez combien je suis
attaché à l'industrie française et à sa
compétitivité j'ai d'ailleurs signé dans
la presse début octobre avec Olivier
marlex et Laurent marcangelli une
tribune intitulé pour un partage de la
compétitivité nucléaire avec l'industrie
pouvez-vous nous convaincre que les
réformes annoncées vont dans ce sens
madame la ministre vous avez la
parole
monsieur le Président cher Guillaume
casbarian mesdames et messieurs les
députés je vous remercie d'organiser au
sein de votre commission une audition
sur l'accord européen et sur notre
future régulation nationale du marché de
l'électricité l'aboutissement de ces
deux négociations est un apport majeur à
notre futur énergétique le président de
la République s'y était engagé nous
l'avons fait cet aboutissement constitue
une réponse forte aux Hauses record des
prix de l'énergie et au bouleversement
de nos circuits d'approvisionnement
engendrés par l'agression de l'Ukraine
par la Russie il est un élément
essentiel pour bâtir la souveraineté
énergétique de notre pays et reprendre
le contrôle sur les prix d'électricité
comme l'a souhaité le président de la
République ces deux négociations
accompagnent une stratégie énergétique
déterminée pour produire massivement
l'énergie décarbonés nucléaair comme
renouvelable et pour poursuivre notre
mobilisation générale en faveur de la
sobriété et de l'efficacité énergétique
il n'y a pas d'autre chemin si nous
voulons demain répondre aux besoins
massif d'électricité que nous anticipons
je pense à l'électrification des
transports ou au processus industriels
que nous décarbonons avec par exemple
les contrats engagés avec 50 sites
industriels les plus émetteurs il n'y a
pas d'autrees chemin si nous voulons
rester dans la course mondiale face aux
États-Unis et à la Chine une France
souveraine c'est une France qui maîtrise
sa production et sa consommation
d'énergie avec le président de la
République et la majorité présidentielle
nous avons posé les fondations pour
bâtir cette souveraineté énergétique et
concilier lutte contre les dérèglement
climatiqu et compétitivité de notre pays
sur le plan européen d'abord aujourd'hui
le nucléaire enfin oseraiis-je dire
n'est plus un tabou à Bruxelles c'était
pourtant loin d'être évident mais j'ai
fait le choix de porter ce combat
pendant que d'autres n'ont cessé de
prener une sortie inopérante du marché
européen de l'énergie casser le
thermomètre ne fait pas tomber la fièvre
ce combat qui doit beaucoup je veux le
souligner à la délégation renue au
Parlement européen a été couronné de
succès il s'est incarné dans l'alliance
du nucléaire que j'ai créé qui rassemble
14 États-membres cette alliance qui a
permis de remporter des victoire majeur
pour faire reconnaître comme une énergie
indispensable le nucléaire à notre futur
décarboné il a permis de retenir un
principe de neutralité technologique
dans des textes majeurs comme la
directive renouvelable ou la réforme du
marché de l'électricité il a permis de
défendre la filière nucléaire
d'excellence européenne et française
avec la création par exemple d'une
alliance industriel desmr annoncé par la
Commission européenne ou l'inclusion des
technologies nucléaires dans le net zero
industrial Act cette alliance a enfin
permis d'obtenir un succès sur la
réforme du marché de
l'électricité comme vous le savez cette
réforme visait un triple objectif
déconnecter les prix du gaz de ceux de
l'électricité pour empêcher les envolés
de nos prixélectricité comme nous
l'avons connu lorsqu'il y a des
situations de tension sur le marché des
énergies fossiles stabiliser les prix
l'électricité sur le long terme deuxième
objectif sécuriser nos
approvisionnements énergétiques grâce à
la solidarité européenne 3è
objectif cet accord qui a été obtenu et
qui a permis d'atteindre ces trois
objectifs est une étape importante pour
améliorer le fonctionnement européen et
engager une réforme de notre régulation
nationale dans les meilleures conditions
sur le plan national nous vivons un
point de bascule si notre pays a réussi
le Paris de décarboner sa production
d'électricité grâce au choix historique
de construire un des plus grands parcs
nucléaires au monde nous devons
aujourd'hui décarboner l'ensemble de
notre mix énergétique où les énergies
fossiles continuent à peser 60 % de
notre consommation d'énergie totale
alors très peu le charbon mais beaucoup
de gaz et beaucoup de pétrole pour
réussir ce défi je le redis nous avons
quatre leviers à disposition pour
lesquels nous fixons un très haut degré
d'ambition la sobriété l'efficacité
énergétique les énergies renouvelable et
le nucléaire je mobiliserai ces quatre
leviers car refuser de mobiliser un de
ces leviers par idéologie est
irresponsable et compréettrait gravement
l'atteinte de nos ambitions énergétiques
et climatiques surtout l'atteinte de
notre souveraineté économique et
énergétique en prenant 100 % du capital
de DF nous avons assumé de faire de
cette entreprise de service public le
bras armé de notre politique énergétique
nous faisons choix de prolonger autant
que possible dans respect des conditions
de sûreté de haut niveau notre parc
existant de 56 réacteurs nous avons
lancé un programme de construction de 6
PR2 et la mise à l'étude de H8
supplémentaires ce programme c'est une
nouvelle épopée industrielle et doit
être une fierté pour notre pays pour nos
territoirees pour les emplois que nous
créerons grâce à cette relance nous
renons enfin avec l'esprit de la France
des bâtisseurs nous investissons
également massivement dans laaval et
laamonde du CYC ainsi que dans des
projets de recherche et de mise au point
de futurs réacteurs mobulaires pour que
notre pays reste à la pointe
technologique j'ai d'ailleurs annoncé
lundi dans le cadre du World nuclear
energy forum six nouveaux lauréat du
plan France 2030 pour développer des
smmr l'enveloppe d'un milliard d'euros
pour de France 2030 soutient ainsi au
total projets innovant de nouveaux
réacteurs modulaires et d'autres
poursuivent actuellement leur
instruction c'est dans ce contexte que
nous avions avec Bruno Le Maire engagé
des négociations avec EDF pour définir
une régulation du marché de
l'électricité qui succédera à la Renne
en 2026 l'accord que nous avons obtenu
et qui est actuellement mise en
consultation publique a trouvé un
équilibre essentiel entre la
compétitivité de notre industrie la
stabilisation des prix pour les ménages
et la capacité pour EDF de poursuivre
son développement et ses
investissements loin de proposition de
loi irresponsable que votre commission a
d'ailleurs légitimement rejeté c'est
accord fixe des paramètres clairs il
garantit un prix d'électricité nucléaire
moyen autour de 70 € du mgawh en euro
2022 ce prix est à la fois un gage de
stabilité de visibilité et de protection
des Français et des entreprises un gage
de stabilité car il permettra de
prévenir toute nouvelle envolée des prix
comme nous l'avons connu c'est un
impératif majeur pour le pouvoir d'achat
des Français pour la compétitivité de
notre économie et pour la
réindustrialisation de notre pays il
permettra également de couvrir à la fois
de façon soutenable l'ensemble des coûts
du nucléaire existant ainsi que les
investissement futur en particulier le
programme nouveau nucléaire c'est
deuxièmement un gage de visibilité car
il permettra de développer des contrats
de long terme c'est une révolution
majeure par rapport au contrats actuels
qui sont de court terme
EDF mettra en place une politique
commerciale adapté aux besoins des
différents consommateurs il proposera
d'abord aux industriels et contrat de
partenariat industriel de long terme
avec un partage des risques
EDF s'engagera à assurer la vente de sa
production sur des horizons plus long
par ailleurs à moyen terme 4 à 5 ans ce
qui permettra également aux fournisseurs
alternatifs de bâtir des offres de long
terme et les incitera à développer leur
propre capacités de production ou à
s'adosser à de nouvelles capacités de
production un gage de protection des
Français et des entreprises enfin car il
met en place un mécanisme de
redistribution des bénéfices au-delà de
niveau de prix défini il s'agit en
d'autres termes d'un mécanisme anticrise
pour amortir une future hausse des prix
il s'agit d'un bouclier tarifaire
permanent qui ne pèse pas sur les
finances publiques pour rappel le
bouclier tarifaire d'électricité a coûté
40 milliards d'euros deux nouveaux de
prélèvements sont fixés un premier
prélèvement partiel au-delà d'un premier
seuil autour de 80 € du mgawh en euro
2022 puis un prélèvement quasi total
au-delà d'un second seuil supérieur à
100 € autour de 110 € du M MW en euro
2022 cette nouvelle régulation permet de
corriger plusieurs défauts du marché
actuel qui l'ont lourdement pesé dans la
crise énergétique elle permet d'abord de
déconnecter les prix l'électricité du
prix du gaz c'est une aberration qui
devait être corrigée puisqu'elle est à
l'origine de la flambée des prix
deélectricité une aberération contre
laquelle le mécanisme de régulation
précédent l'arine ne nous a
malheureusement pas protégé en 2022
elle mettra fin à certains défaut de
l'arineine puisque la redistribution se
fera directement au consommateur quel
que soit le fournisseur sans guichet
réservé au fournisseurs alternatif comme
c'est actuellement le cas ça ira donc
directement sur la facture des
consommateurs c'est une garantie de
transparence vis-à-vis de ces
consommateurs elle préservera enfin les
tarifs réglementés pour les ménages et
les petites entreprises ils seront
d'ailleurs étendus à toutes les TPE
puisque nous supprimerons le seuil de
puissance maximale de 36 kVA c'est une
évolution qui était très attendue un mot
enfin sur les modalités de mise en œuvre
de cette nouvelle régulation cette
future régulation devrait être inscrite
dans la loi
elle figurera ainsi dans la future loi
de souveraineté énergétique de la France
qui sera présentée en conseil des
ministres en début d'année prochaine je
doute pas que nous aurons d'ici là des
opportunités d'échanger sur ce texte à
venir je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame la ministre je vous propose de
passer aux orateurs de groupe vous
connaissez le principe 4 minutes par
orateur de groupe inclus votre réponse
et je coupe à 3 minutes grand maximum
pour l'orateur qui s'exprime on va
commencer tout de suite avec le groupe
Renaissance et c'est Éric botorel qui
prend la parole merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre chers
collègues pour répondre à nos besoins
croissants en énergie décarbonée
respecter nos engagements pour le climat
et renforcer notre indépendance
énergétique la France agit nos objectifs
pour 2050 sont ambitieux construction de
6 nouveaux pr multiplication par 10 de
la capacité de production d'énergie
solaire déploiement de 50 parcs éoliens
en mer la stratégie que nous portons se
fonde sur un mix énergétique décarboné
comp poser l'énergie nucléaire et des
énergies renouvelables en même temps en
même temps c'est le sens des deux lois
votées en début d'année par notre
Parlement à une large majorité dans ce
cadre la réforme du marché européen
l'électricité est bienvenue d'autant
plus que la position de la France a été
entendue par les 27 ainsi l'énergie
nucléaire aura toute sa place dans la
stratégie européenne nous permettant de
sécuriser notre approvisionnement en
énergie décarboné et de reprendre le
contrôle des prix de l'électricité aussi
pourriez-vous nous éclairer sur les
garanties de voir ce compromis maintenu
jusqu'au bout du processus législatif
européen au-delà comment ne pas évoquer
les annonces du président de la
République hier aux Assises de la m sur
l'éolien offshore je sais madame la
ministre que c'est une thématique qui
vous est chère et qui a fait l'objet un
déplacement dans ma circonscription il y
a maintenant quelques
semaines le président bien sûr le
président a entre autres confirmé
l'appel d'offre massive de 10 GW
d'éoliens en mer en 2025 soit une
dizaine de pars qui seront mis en
service d'ici 2035 il a également
annoncé un investissement 200 millions
d'euros pour l'éoliens flotant de nos
infrastructures portuaires c'est une
excellente nouvelle pour le respect de
nos engagements pour le climat et pour
le soutien à notre économie mis nos
emplois je rappelle ici que le seul parc
éolien de Saint-Brieux a créé plus de
1700 emplois en France dont 500 rien
qu'en Bretagne et couvrira 9 % de la
consommation énergétique bretonne
dééolien en mer et la locomotive des
énergies marines renouvelables dans
l'Hexagone avec plus de 7500 emplois et
près de 2 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaire l'an passé s'inscrivant un
pleinement dans notre ambition
d'atteindre le plein emploi aussi madame
la ministre pourriez-vous nous décliner
la méthode et les prochaines étapes
concernant la construction de ces
nouveaux parcs je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la ministre
c'est
bon euh alors s'agissant de la
négociation d'électricité market design
vous savez que les trilogues sont en
cours on je je vais pas présumer de de
l'atterrissage de ces trilogues mais il
a été clairement exprimé par l'alliance
du nucléaire que l'équilibre du texte
qui a été obtenu difficilement en
Conseil européen ne saurait être remis
en cause s'agissant du fameux article
19b dans lequel enfin qui a donné lieu
aux dernières négociations sur le reste
du texte notamment le le volet
protection du consommateur je crois que
le Parlement européen cherche souhaite
renforcer certains éléments ce qui nous
nous paraît tout à fait en tout cas
discutable acceptable
pour pour des raisons évidente
d'amélioration du fonctionnement du
marché européen on se souvient tous des
situations où euh certains fournisseur
d'électricité avaient brutalement
disparu du marché au moment de la crise
mettant en difficulté leur
consommateurs s'agissant de l'éolien en
mer très rapidement nous allons
effectivement lancer ce dialogue
stratégique de façade il s'agit de 45 GW
45 GW en 2050 c'est l'équivalent de 13
PR2 donc quand on dit qu'on réfléchit à
6 pr + 8 additionnel c'est vous dire
l'importance de ce projet en terme de
production d'électricité je parle même
pas de
gigw connecté en terme de production
d'électricité attendue c'est 25 % de
notre mix énergétique à horizon
2050 donc c'est
considérable avec le projet de loi que
vous avez voté on gagne plusieurs années
on gagne surtout on donne de la
visibilité à la fois aux usagers de la
mer dans tout leur usage ou dans toutes
leurs fonction la fonction de
biodiversité étant très importante mais
les pêcheurs les transporteurs le
tourisme les collectivités locales
et on permet surtout de planifier les
futurs projets mon objectif est de
pouvoir lancer des appels d'offre à
compté de 2025 sur un volume de 10 Gow
10 GW c'est grosso modo 20 parcs de
saint-nazer que nous aurions vocation à
connecter ensuite d'ici 2035 avec par
ailleurs tout un travail qui est fait
par l'État pour améliorer les études de
connaissance de la biodiversité en
mettant des crédits sur cette
amélioration de la connaissance qui
permet dérisquer les projets mais
également nous-même de disposer de
données pour l'instruction des
autorisations environnementales 50
millions d'euros dans le budget actuel
et avec un travail d'accompagnement de
la filière pour lui donner la visibilité
et conforter les emplois puisque vous
savez que il est possible que cette
filière passe un moment difficile de
trou d'air dans son carnet de commande
parce que nous avons nous dans notre
carnet de commande des choses qui
arrivent un peu en décalé et que le
reste de l'Europe et du monde euh plin
un petit peu en ce moment enfin est est
en difficulté et donc je souhaite qu'on
ait un pacte éolien qui permette aussi
de soutenir cette filière qui représente
30 % de la production européenne merci
j'ai légèrement débordé excusez-moi
chers collègues pour le rassemblement
national nous avons Nicolas maisonet qui
prend la parole pour le groupe merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
après 6 ans de revirement et de
contradiction il nous est toujours
impossible de comprendre le sens de
votre politique énergétique et les
Français nous en sonmt témoins
alors que DF accuse une dette de 64,5
milliards d'euros et que les factures
d'électricité des Français ne cessent de
s'alourdir notre pays a plus que jamais
besoin qu'une ligne claire soit définie
inutile de répéter les les avantages
précieux et uniques au monde de notre
modèle de production d'électricité la
fameuse complémentarité hydraulique
nucléaire elle aurait dû être suffisante
pour répondre à nos besoins aujourd'hui
si vous et vos prédécesseurs n'aviez pas
tout bonnement saboté la filière
nucléaire depuis 15 ans
nous et nous sommes tout aussi inquiets
pour la filière hydraulique aujourd'hui
elle qui est l'indispensable corelaire
de notre de notre nucléaire elle ne
saurait être bradée sous couvert
d'ouverture à la concurrence en
sous-investissant en programmant la
diminution drastique de la part du
nucléaire et en fermant la centrale de
festenheim vous avez fait preuve d'une
naïveté confondante et j'ose croire
qu'il ne s'agit que de naïveté madame la
ministre naïveté partagé par nos
collègues insoumis ou écolos qui eux
n'en seront probable jamais guéri dans
la ligée des gouvernements qui se
succèdent depuis 20 ans vous avez laissé
le nucléaire français se faire attaquer
par des pays où la production
d'électricité est plus chè mais surtout
nettement plus polluante comme
l'Allemagne dans l'illusion de créer une
concurrence laarine a contribué
massivement à déstabiliser notre
producteur historique même Bruno Le
Maire aujourd'hui en convient et vous
n'avez jamais jamais voulu le remettre
en question malgré sa nocivité alors que
vous auriez vous en auriez eu l'occasion
depuis 6 ans en parallèle vous avez
encouragé et surtout subventionné le
développement hasardeux de l'éolien et
du solaire alors même que ces énergies
intermittentes nous rendent dépendant
des centrales à gaz et à charbon
aujourd'hui enfin nous sommes à l'OB
d'un défi industriel titanesque la
relance du nucléire dans notre pays vous
prévalez d'un nouvel accord sur les prix
de l'électricité dont on doute encore
des effets positifs pour les
particuliers les entreprises mais aussi
de la reconnaissance du nucléaire comme
industrie verte par Bruxelles c'est bien
pourtant le chemin euh à parcourir
semble encore immense alors vous arrivez
aujourd'hui avec cette fusion de l'IRSN
et de l'ASN si elle est bien
réalisée pourrait avoir une certaine
utilité mais là encore n'est-ce pas
dérisoire au regard du sentier
nécessaire 14 réacteurs comment fait-on
comment expliquer que vous soyez passé
d'une fusion mise en place en deux
amendements un projet de loi aujourd'hui
à en 18 articles et comment s'assurer
que ce dernier n'est pas un éniè coup de
comme entre deux projets au lien en
matière de ressources humaines
d'investissement et de logistique la
relance du nucléaire exige une
mobilisation inédite et doit faire
l'objet d'un consensus dans votre
gouvernement et votre majorité
pouvez-vous désormais madame la ministre
me dire clairement si oui ou non devant
les EnR devant les EnR le nucléaire
constitue bien une priorité absolue pour
votre gouvernement le nucléaire est-il
bien dans votre projet merci beaucoup
madame la ministre en une
minute si de revirement vous faites
référence à la votre présidente de
groupe qui a eu des sincérités
successives sur le nucléaire je
pense non non je manifester vos
sincérités successives il faut savoir le
reconnaître et effectivement nous sommes
au pouvoir depuis 6 ans et nous avons
relancé la filière du nucléaire puisque
j'étais à la manœuvre personnellement au
moment du lancement de l'étude RTE qui
demandait à étudier des scénari sur le
nucléaire en 2020 au fait que dans le
plan de relance le nucléaire figurait
dans les six secteurs prioritaires
soutenus par le plan de relance dans la
filière industrielle au fait qu'en 2021
nous avons présenter un scénario de
relance du nucléaire dans la partie
construction défense au fait qu'en 2022
le président de la République annoncé la
relance de la filière nucléaire au-delà
de sa vision stratégique pour le pays en
matière énergétique sobriété efficacité
énergétique renouvelable et nucléaire et
donc nous nous ne pardon y terminé non
mais termin juste sur le développement
has R2 de l'éolien il va falloir à un
moment que vous vous mettiez au
mathématiques sans renouvelable il y
aura un mur énergétique en face de nous
sans renouvelable il y aura un mur
énergétique en face de nous et la
cohérence de notre politique c'est
évidemment le en même temps je vous
remercie nous passons au groupe la
France insoumise et c'est Maxime lén qui
porte la parole de son groupe merci
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chers collègues dans ma circonscription
comme partout dans le pays les files
d'attente des Restos du cœur s'allongent
pour cause d'inflation sur l'alimentaire
mais aussi d'explosion des prix de
l'énergie et vous inventez une nouvelle
usine à gaz après avoir fanfaronné sur
une grande victoire française obtenue
dans la négociation européenne vous avez
finalement cédé aux exigences contraires
du PDG dEDF et vous vous entêtez dans
des rustines sur des mécanisme de marché
un marché qui ne peut pas marcher quand
on parle d'électricité ni pour assurer
la stabilité et la visibilité sur les
prix ni pour assurer les investissements
nécessaires encore moins pour assurer
l'égal accès à ce bien de première
nécessité c'est ce que nous ont dit les
économistes et représentants de
consommateurs lors du colloc que nous
avons organisé le 26 octobre ces experts
ont également insisté sur l'inepsie de
s'obstiné à vouloir faire des usagers
des traders ainsi que sur l'inutilité
des fournisseurs alternatifs qui ne
fournissent rien d'autre que la facture
et dont l'existence même fait
nécessairement monter les prix vous
sortez donc du chapeau pour remplacer
laarine un tarif cible de 70 € du mgawh
comme prix de vente par EDF de son
énergie nucléaire à ses fameux
fournisseurs et dont les dépassements
au-delà de 80 € seraient taxés pour être
reversé au consommateurs mais combien
pour qui comment nul ne le sait un tarif
qui maintient un écart important entre
coût de production dont la creux estime
qu'il ne dépassera pas 57 € du mgawh sur
la période 2026-2030 et prix au
consommateurs dont nul ne peut garantir
le niveau d'autant que personne ne
comprend comment serit calculer demain
les tarifs réglementés avant leur
disparition programmée des trve qui vont
à nouveau grimper de 10 % au 1er février
prochain après avoir bondi de plus de 70
% en 10 ans notons que ce tarif
surévalué sert en fait à financer la
relance du nucléaire qui arriverait de
toute façon trop tard pour permettre de
décarboner notre économie d'ici 250 vous
êtes tombé d'accord avec Monsieur
Raymond pour que DF puisse signer des
contrats de gré à gré avec des
entreprises électrointensives qui
investiraient dans les nouveaux
réacteurs en échange d'un volume
d'électricité et d'un prixable sur
plusieurs années et là plusieurs
questions se posent le contribuable
couvrira-t-il le risque de défaillance
deedf auprès de ses gros clients à
l'inverse que se passera-t-il si un un
industriel fait faillite ces contrats
peuvent-ils être conclus avec des
entreprises étrangères et si des
délestages sont pressentis comme l'hiver
dernier va-t-on couper le courant au
ménag PME et collectivité pour le
réserver à ses gros clients
potentiellement étrangers à l'inverse
des mirages libéraux dans lesquels vous
vous obstinez nous proposons le retour à
un opérateur public national intégré
allant de la production à la fourniture
ce retour à une maîtrise publique pleine
et entière permettrait ainsi de proposer
des tarifs fondés sur les coûts de
production réels ainsi qu'un pilotage
optimisé du système Syme ce qui
n'empêcherait nullement les échanges
avec nos voisins et qui emporterait à
coup sûr l'adhésion des salariés de
l'opérateur historique madame la
ministre votre gouvernement fait croire
depuis des mois à une nationalisation
deedf alors dites-nous ce qui
empêcherait de mettre en œuvre notre
proposition finalement assez simple et
assez évidente merci beaucoup madame la
ministre oui alors je vais répondre
point à point à votre question d'abord
cette régulation permet d'avoir des
tarifs fondés sur les coûts de
production réel ainsi que sur les
investissements futurs et vous faites
référence au calcul de de la creux sauf
que méthodologiquement vous oubliez de
mentionner que ce calcul de la creux ne
n'intègre pas les investissements dans
le futur nucléaire de même qu'il intègre
la possibilité pour EDF dans son calcul
d'avoir un prix plancher le fait qu'elle
qu'il n''est plus de prix plancher ce
qui permettra aussi de faire baisser les
factures a donc un coût je rentre pas
dans le détail du calcul du coût moyen
du capital mais c'est comme ça qu'on
reconstitue les 70 €. et je je trouve
assez émouvant cette brusque mise en
cause de DF après nous avoir expliqué
que nous mettions à genou ce formidable
euh en organisation et entreprise qui
assure le service public 2ème élément
bien sûr qu'il y aura des tarifs
réglementé c'est même un engagement que
nous prenons et nous les euh nous les
étendons non seulement au ménages qui
n'auront pas à faire des activités de
trading bien continuer à avoir des
tarifs réglementés mais également à
toutes les TPE y compris plus cell le
plus de 36 KVR s'agissant des
fournisseurs alternatifs vous avez
raison de pointer du doigt que certains
d'entre eux n'ont pas fait n'ont pas eu
ce rôle de développement de nouvelles
capacités de production et c'est bien
pour ça que ce système de régulation les
incite à développer de nouvelles
capacités de production et
qu'accessoirement toute la partie
prudentielle euh et régulatoire est
renforcée pour mieux protéger les
consommateurs contre des pratiques qui
ne seraient pas accepbl de la part de
ces fournisseur alternatif enfin sur le
partage des risques l'effacement est
évidemment un des éléments des contrats
sinon ça ne serait pas un partage des
risques merci nous passons au groupe les
républicains c'est Hibo Bazin qui porte
la parole de son groupe merci monsieur
le Président j'ai beaucoup de questions
madame la ministre de la transition
énergétique nous vous avions reproché
votre politique énergétique durant le
précédent quinquena ne remettant pas en
cause le désengagement nucléaire de la
France engagé sous François Hollande
cela nous a amené dans la situation
actuelle avec une envolée des prix de
l'électricité nousous réjouissons de
votre changement de politique nucléaire
que nous appelions nos vœux après avoir
envisagé de fermer une grande partie de
notre parc nucléaire vous prolongez
finalement dans les conditions de sûreté
les 56 réacteurs et vous envisagez si
nouveaux PRD et h complémentaires à
l'étude or notre programmation
plurannuelle de l'énergie n'a toujours
pas été corrigée toute la filière a
besoin de visibilité vous annoncez la
présentation de la loi de souverainé
énergétique en janvier prochain quel
sera le calendrier d'examen et quel
objectif calendaire d'adoption
définitive pour faire suite à l'accord
entre DF et le gouvernement sur le prix
de d'électricité à partir de 2026 je
souhaite vous questionner sur le
mécanisme de captation de la rende de DF
qui reste encore très flou et donne
aujourd'hui un caractère imprévisible au
prix à la facture des Français que
répondez-vous aux inquiétudes
grandissantes des industriels qui
préférerent un système de régulation
exanté que répondez-vous à la critique
de manque de transparence autour de
l'élaboration de de l'accord qui ne
porte d'ailleurs aucune garantie de
séparation des activités de producteurs
et de fournisseurs d'EDF autre question
les 70 € du mgawatt valent-t-il pour 1 2
ou 10 ans en d'autres termes est-ce
qu'en fonction des coûts du marché c'est
surceptit d'être évalié en partant de
l'hypothèse de 70 €. quelle est la
projection à production constante
d'électricité pour les futures réserves
financières de DF en milliards d'euros
qu'est-ce que cela signifie en terme de
désendettement enfin l'Union européenne
va avoir besoin de 584 milliards d'euros
d'investissement pour moderniser ses
réseaux électriques d'ici à 2030 elle
s'emploie aujourd'hui à trouver les
moyens de les financer ce qui signifie
qu'en France le TURPE va augmenter
a-t-on une idée de l'augmentation totale
pour le consommateur Turp plus
production nucléaire de la facture
finale merci Madame Laam vous avez un
bon 2 minutes pour
répondre
alors Monsieur Bazin alors vous sur les
différents éléments donc comme je
l'indiqué he le système est un
prélèvement de 50 % de la rente au-delà
de 80 € l'équivalent de 80 € du mgawh là
on a une vision 2022 au momentù ça
s'appliquera c'est-à-dire à partir de
50 % sur l'ensemble de la production
nucléaire et de 90 % à peu près 90 à 100
% sur l'ensemble de la production
nucléaire au-delà de l'équivalent de 110
€ tarif
2022 ce tarif il n'évolue pas en
fonction des coûts du marché il évolue
en fonction des coûts de production
c'est bien la promesse c'est que ça
évolue en fonction des coûts de
production ces coûts de production ils
prennent en compte un niveau de
productible de 360 € du terraw ils
prennent en compte l'ensemble des
investissements dans le grand carénage
dans la les centrales existantes je
dirais le tout venant et il prend en
compte une partie enfin le des
investissements dans le nouveau
nucléaire c'est ça la construction de
ces 70 € donc c'est vraiment caler sur
les coûts de production de notre
nucléaire c'était la promesse qui avait
prise le président de la République et
c'est ce que nous tenons
ici s'agissant de du manque alors des
des des inquiétudes nous allons
évidemment y travailler alors
premièrement la transparence il est
évident puisque c'est la loi que le
tarif d'un acte qui est en situation de
par de marché importante sur un marché
c'est la transparence et la la
réplicabilité et donc ces éléments là
devront être respectés et la présidente
de la creux et son la creux y travaille
deuxème 2è élément vous mentionnez qu'il
n'y a pas de séparation des activités de
production et de commercialisation de
def je je est-ce que vous nous demandez
de couper en plusieurs morceaux F non on
a je voulais juste être sûr de
ça
s'agissant
s'agissant on laisse terminer madame la
ministre je je je je crois comprendre
que Bruno Lemire avait lui-même indiqué
que le projet Hercule n'avait plus de
raison d'être s'agissant des réseaux
vous avez raison c'est une augmentation
qui va rentrer en ligne de compte dans
les années qui viennent je rappelle que
les investissements ils portent sur les
17 ans qui viennent donc c'est une c'est
quelques euros par an
et là aussi on est fondé sur les coûts
de production c'est dire
qu'effectivement notre objectif
aujourd'hui est d'avoir des coûts de
production les plus compétitif possible
ça veut dire produire le plus de
nucléaire possible merci beaucoup nous
continuons avec le groupe démocrate et
c'est Romain dobier qui porte la parole
du
groupe merci monsieur le Président
bonjour madame le le ministre je
souhaiterais tout d'abord saluer au nom
du du groupe les accords extrêmement
importants qui ont été conclus ces
dernières semaines sur la réforme
européen de l'électricité celui avec Ed
sur les futurs prix du du nucléaire la
France a démontré si on était encore
besoin que l'Union européenne reste un
espace dans lequel on peut discuter de
nos règles communes permettant à chacun
de tirer profit de cette union nous
démontrons surtout que la France
demeurera une puissance économique de
premier plan doté d'une énergie bon
marché grâce au nucléaire et à nos
investissements dans les renouvelables
l'accord trouvé avec EDF ne correspond
pas exactement au fameux CFD négocié
dans le cadre de l'accord européen car
on n'y retrouve pas le prix plancher je
souhaite ainsi en savoir plus sur les
discussions que vous avez avec la
Commission européenne concernant cet
accord notamment sur les deux points qui
demandent des précisions à C à 7 heure à
savoir la redistribution des sommes
captées au-dessus des de seuils et sur
les relations avec les fournisseurs
alternatifs pourriez-vous nous éclairer
et enfin je me réjouis de l'annonce du
ministre de l'économie concernant les
accords avec EDF sur les tarifs régulés
pour les petites entreprises en passant
du seuil avant des 30 du des 36 MWh à 10
salariés et et de et moins de 2 millions
de de chiffres d'affaires qui permettra
notamment à nos nos boulangers qui sont
nos commerces de proximité de nos
village de pas subir cette hausse et de
pas les répertorier sur les les
concitoyens voilà en quelques mots ce
que je pourrais vous poser merci Madame
la Ministre
oui alors en fait l'accord est
parfaitement respecté parce que l'accord
il se déclenche si vous d'abord euh la
partie CFD pour les installations
nucléaires existantes constitue une
optionnalité pas une obligation et par
ailleurs elle s'applique en cas de dette
d'État lorsqu'il n'y a pas de dette
d'État par construction il y a pas
besoin de d'avoir cette cette approche
donc cette cet accord que nous avons
trouvé avec EDF il respecte l'esprit de
l'accord que nous avons trouvé au niveau
européen c'est-à-dire la volonté de
prolonger la maturité de diminuer la
volatilité de nos contrats d'électricité
encore une fois l'enjeu que nous
poursuivons que ce soit au niveau
européen ou au niveau français c'est de
diminuer l'exposition du système
électrique européen et français à au
prix du fossile premier point faire en
sorte d'avoir une incitation à produire
plus d'énergie décarbonée et
d'électricité au cas d'espèces en Europe
pour baisser les prix la façon dont on
baisse les prix c'est d'avoir plus
d'abondance d'électricité et donner de
la visibilité aux acteurs industriels
comme aux acteur producteur d'énergie et
donc tant dans le premier accord que
dans celui que nous avons avec EDF ces
éléments-là sont effectivement bien
respecté merci beaucoup je vous propose
de passer au groupe socialiste et c'est
Marie Noë btistelle qui porte la parole
du
groupe oui merci monsieur le Président
merci d'avoir accédé à la demande de
d'inviter madame la ministre rapidement
puisque les sujets entre le projet de
fusion ASN RSN les négociations
européennes l'accord avec EDF sur les
prix post Aren il y a évidemment nombre
de questions donc je vais me limiter à
quelques-unes l'audition de Monsieur
dorozuk il y a quelques semaine laisser
entendre que d'autres entreprises KDF
pourraient exploiter demain des
réacteurs nucléaires classiques ou SMR
la recherche et la conception c'est une
chose l'exploitation s'en est une autre
qu'en est-il pouvez-vous nous rassurer
pouvez-vous confirmer le monopole
d'exploitation d'EDF sur le parc
électronucléaire futur sur l'accord post
arenne avec EDF sur les prix de
l'électricité on entend des
interprétations divergentes de
spécialistes sur le caractère
potentiellement soumis à la
réglementation sur les aides d'État du
mécanisme retenu quelle est votre
analyse quelles sont vos assurances sur
ce dispositif et si la commission devait
considérer cet accord contraire à la
réglementation à la matière quel sera
votre plan B certains regrettent le
manque de transparence et craignent le
caractère imprévisible des prix et la
facture des consommateurs que leur
répondez-vous
sur le fond de l'accord les clauses de
revoyure semblent d'ors et déjà prévu ce
qui laisse peut-être supposer que
celui-ci n'intègre que partiellement à
ce stade le financement du nucléaire
futur voire du Grand carinage selon le
retour de l'ASN donc que recoupe
précisément le niveau de prix
aujourd'hui annoncé
comment
répartions nous le reversement d'EDF à
l'état au-delà des 78 €os vous dites que
ce sera en direction les consommateurs
très bien particulier collectivité euh
entreprise électrointensif quel va être
le le l'étendue de la mesure s'agissant
des fournisseurs alternatifs
confirmez-vous qu'il n'existera plus de
dispositifs spécifiques les concernants
et qu'ils se sourceront soit sur les
marchés soit sur leur production propre
sur la stratégie énergie climat mise en
consultation publique nous n'y trouvons
pas les conditions suffisantes à la
forte accélération des ENR sur la
période
2025-235 qui est la période où nous
n'aurons pas encore de nouveaux
nucléaires et où la prolongation du parc
existant que l'on souhaite mais qui
reste incertaine alors comment
comptez-vous faire le joint pour réduire
le risque de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement sur
l'hydroélectricité et le changement le
projet de changement de régime en
passage du régime concessif au régime
d'autorisation comment trait c'estv la
spécificité de la concession du rô avec
son triple
objet et je crois que je vais m'en
arrêter là sinon vous aurez pas le temps
de répondre à toutes mes questions et
peut-être est-ce que la loi de
souveraineté c'est la lpec ou c'est
autre chose bien alors pour ces très
nombreuses questions vous avez une
minute madame la
ministre oui alors je vais essayer de
répondre à questions qui ont pas déjà
été posé comme ça ça permet de d'ouvrir
sur d'autres sujets sur l'exploitation
de réacteurs je pense je pense que vous
mentionnez l'exploitation de smmr je
vous rassurer je pense qu'avant 2030 il
y aura pas de réacteur connectés puisque
l'objectif de la
lpec autre que ce que nous connaissons
déjà qui sont des pr l'objectif de la de
la stratégie française énergie climat
que vous connaissez bien pour y avoir
contribué et qui que nous avons publié
et soumise à la concertation c'est une
premierère coulée de béton de SMR en
bon non non mais moi je je pense que le
législateur de de de 2030 ou de 2040
pourra prendre position mais je je veux
juste parce que j'ai entendu que c'était
un sujet qui allait seoser dans les
semaines qui viennent d'autre part je
pense que c'est pas le cas sur la
question des énergies renouvelables je
veux juste dire que comme vous avez pu
le constater les les curseurs sont
poussés au maximum énergie renouvelable
par énergie renouvelable avec
effectivement la possibilité enfin il y
a un pied pilote puisque moi j'accepte
avec plaisir que la filière
photovoltaïque triple son rythme de
déploiement mais je ne peux pas me
permettre de mettre en risque le pays si
elle ne fait que le doubler ce qui est
déjà une jolie performance et donc vous
avez un système que je pousse d'avoir
plutôt une forme de cliquer et sur
l'hydroélectrique euh effectivement nous
sommes en train de regarder avec la CNR
mais la CNR est bien à bord avec une
complexité particulière que vous
manifestez puisqu'elle a un triple objet
de service
public merci beaucoup que ce que nous
disait l'ASN quand il était venu c'est
qu'il y avait des dossiers de demande
d'exploitation future qui étaient
arrivés sur la table et que l'ASN ne
pouvait pas les excures parce que la loi
ne prévoit pas de monopole
d'exploitation c'est c'est
ça oui mais comme on c'est comme on est
législateur et qu'on fait la loi on sait
donc par conséquent qu'aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas dans la loi un monopole
d'exploitation et qu'on ne peut pas par
la loi interdire à l'ASN d'étudier et
d'examiner une demande d'exploitation
notamment pour des process industriels
décarbon futur qui utiliseraiit des SMR
ou d'autres technologies nucléaires
c'était ça le le sujet hein et et et
j'ajoute que c'est difficile d'interdire
ça dans la loi à des gens qui n'ont pas
encore trouvé donc laissons les trouver
et puis on organisera le Monop enfin on
organisera les modalités d'exploitation
sachant que les personnalités de
porteuses de CSMR ça peut être aussi des
laboratoires publics ou d'autres acteurs
donc à ce stade il me paraît un tout
petit peu un tout petit peu hatif de
vouloir fermer immédiatement le marché
de se priver de ces solutions de
technologie porteuse et je pense que ça
serait une grave erreur que de vouloir
aller plus vite que la
musique bien pris alors pour le groupe
écologiste nous avons madame Julie
laernous c'est à vous oui j'avoue une
certain rapport d'étonnement sur l'objet
de cette audition et une certaine forme
de colère aussi sur le mépris qu'il y a
visiblement vis-à-vis des parlementaires
je voudrais commencer par la surprise
euh les des tergiversations autour de la
stratégie nationale énergie climat où la
lpec certains d'entre nous ont contribué
au groupe de travail et nous avons été
informés de rien quant au calendrier
parlementaire il me semble aujourd'hui
quand on voit aussi bien les enjeux
énergétiques que climatiques que ça
devrait être une priorité absolue du
gouvernement et donc du Parlement
aujourd'hui il n'en est rien il y a une
concertation qui a été ouverte le 22
novembre dernier qui dure uniquement 3
semaines sur la politique énergétique du
pays c'est plus la stratégie française
énergie- climat pour répondre aux
obligations de l'Union européenne est-ce
que vous pensez sérieusement que 3
semaines suffisent pour concerter
correctement une feuille de route
énergétique et climatique de la France
est-ce que vous allez l'étendre cette
concertation un processus démocratique
qui devrait bien avoir lieu ou est-ce
que c'est juste une manière de nous
imposer nous mettre devant le fait
accombli comme sur de nombreux
sujets plus surprenant le ce document
précise qu'une consultation sera donc
complété par un projet de loi sur la
production énergie vous venez de parler
de loi de souveraineté énergétique
qu'est-ce qu'il faut entendre par cela
là aussi surprise depuis des mois nous
vous interpellons sur le calendrier sur
une loi de programmation sur l'énergie
et le climat qui aurait dû déjà faire
l'objet d'un débat parlementaire et
aujourd'hui vous prendissez donc une loi
de souveraineté énergétique production
énergétique on ne sait plus mais où est
donc passée la partie climat où est
passé la partie sobriété efficacité
énergétique comment peut-on aujourd'hui
faire l'impasse sur les enjeux
climatiques je voudrais aussi exprimer
là mon interrogation nous avons
auditionné en commission desdat et CAE
le président de l'ASN mais nous n'avons
pas eu la chance d'avoir d'audition avec
vous en matière de sûreté du
nucléair j'entends madame la ministre
que vous ne voulez pas prendre le risque
sur la filière du photovoltaïque qui ne
n'atteindrait pas ces objectifs mais
alors sur le nucléaire l'hypothèse de la
prolongation des centrales et
l'ouverture d'un nouvelle pr là-dessus
il n'y a pas de problème il faut foncer
tout de go et brader la sûreté du
nucléaire en
passant il y a là aussi sur la question
du la rénovation et le PLF vous avez
fait des annonces mais les budgets ne
sont pas au rendez-vous sur les
objectifs à atteindre un élément
inquiétant là aussi sur l'accent ou la
priorité qui serait mise sur la
réduction notre consommation de manière
structurelle sur la réforme du marché
puisque c'est d'importance pour
notamment le prix de l'électricité et
qui a donc un impact direct sur les
factures du des Françaises et des
Français il y a un certain nombre de
points de satisfaction mais un certain
nombre de points extrêmement négatifs de
la réforme à commencé par les manigances
de la France concernant le nucléaire
vous avez en effet manigancé pour
inclure le nucléaire existant je
reviendrai sur ce point-là dans une
question complémentaire monsieur le
Président très bien Madame la Ministre
alors je sais pas si c'est du mépris
mais il se trouve que mon cabinet vous a
appelé de son propre chef précisément
pour vous donner tous les détails sur
les éléments que vous mentionnez
notamment le calendrier et les
prochaines étapes de la stratégie
française énergie climat comme je l'ai
fait avec l'ensemble des participants à
ces groupes de travail il fallait venir
monsieur basin
euh mon cabinet donc ensuite deuxème
point les enjeux climatiques nous on
parle pas on les fait la baisse des
émissions de gaz et effet de serre de la
France c'est in 2,7 % l'année dernière
c'est semble-t-il la meilleure
performance des pays du G20 c'est - 4,3
% depuis le début de l'année 1ier
semestre c'est également semble-t-il la
meilleure performance du G20 et je
préfère agir que parler effectivement
3ème point la CNDP a conduit une
concertation de 6 mois sur notre
stratégie française énergie climat donc
je peux pas vous laisser dire qu'il y a
pas eu de concertation et elle a invité
pendant 4 mois l'ensemble des parties
prenantes pour construire cette
stratégie française dont nous avons
repris l'essentiel des propositions donc
là encore il me semble que la
présentation est extrêmement bisée et la
loi de souveraineté énergétique comprend
effectivement un volet programmation
énergétique ça répondra également à
Madame
Baptiste merci Monsieur Sébastien Jumel
pour le groupe GDR merci président
madame la ministre bon la période
récente que nous venons de traverser a
démontré à quel point le libéralisme du
secteur de l'énergie avait pas permis de
faire face aux enjeux d'explosion des
prix de spéculation de concurrence
déloyale de menace de délestage de
manque de main d'œuvre dans de nécessité
d'investissement bon voilà on a sonné le
glas de la libéralisation du secteur de
l'énergie très bien euh vous avez vous
êtes monté au capital de DF à 100 % euh
les tarifs réglementés recouvrent à vos
yeux une forme d'utilité et vous
relancez tardivement mais vous relancez
tout de même la filière nucléaire on
pourrait dire tout va très bien Madame
la marquise mais le député de pand que
je suis reste inquiet alors je mets à
votre actif l'énergie que vous avez
développé pour trouver un accord à
l'échelle européenne c'était pas simple
vous avez trouvé un accord mais j'ai
envie de dire la reine est morte mais le
marché reste roi avec votre affaire
parce que si vous donnez
les moyens à EDF d'investir sur les
carénages d'investir sur le nucléaire du
futur pas beaucoup de réponse sur y
compris la question des réseaux mais le
marché continue de s'emparer du secteur
de l'énergie moi j'ai toujours pas
compris comment allait fonctionner votre
mécanisme de redistribution en cas de de
de de de
tarif
favorable à EDF comment ça marche votre
bidule comment on est sûr que les prix
pour les Français et pour l'économie
réelle seront stabilisés on nen sait
rien parce que quand on écoute Bruno
Lemire en septembre il nous annonce des
hausses de tarifs entre 10 et 20 % en
novembre il les exclus euh bon qui
faut-il croire le ministre de septembre
le ministre de novembre je ne sais pas
je crains également que vous n'ayez pas
renoncé après avoir libéralisé la
demande en créant une concurrence
artificielle sur la fouture la fournit
énergétique à libéraliser la production
je je cite parce que vous dites pourquoi
vous parlez de ça c'est pas d'actu mais
dans l'interview que vous avez prononcé
dans le monde vous dites le système
énergétique doit être reconstruit et
changer de philosophie il était jusqu'à
présent très centralisé autour de
quelques centaines de sites de
production et de quelques grandes
entreprises qui le pilotent à l'avenir
des dizaines de milliers de sites seront
à la fois producteurs et consommateurs
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire cette
histoire qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
cette histoire est-ce que on applique au
nucléaire la anarchie qui a montré son
inefficacité en matière de NR c'est une
question fondamentale que nous vous
posons après avoir auditionné le patron
de l'ASN et puis enfin puisque je parle
de l'ASN alors c'est avec les marcheurs
avec les libéraux c'est un peu comme
dans Big flow et Oli ça va ça va très
vite il faut accélérer faut simplifier
faut accélérer faut simplifier bon enfin
faut pas confondre vitesse et
précipitation non plus je suis vous le
savez un défenseur du nucléaire mais je
suis un défenseur du nucléaire
transparent démocratique sûr rien ne
démontre que votre réforme nous
garantira vitesse merci et sûreté et
transparence et démocratie merci
beaucoup Mons madame la ministre oui
quand je dis qu'il y a des milliers de
sites de production dans notre système
énergétique future il suffit de mettre
un panneau photovoltaïque sur une
toiture et vous devenez producteur et
c'est de ça que je parle et ça c'est une
réalité et alors sauf à ce que vous
vouliez empêcher les milliers de projets
d'énergie renouvelable dans notre pays
mais c'est une intention politique et on
peut l'entendre elle me semble un peu
décalée par rapport au groupe nuups
auquel vous appartenez mais en réalité
c'est bien de ça qu'il s'agit les
énergies renouvelables c'est des
énergies qui sont qui représentent des
milliers de projets chaque année la
deuxième chose sur l'augmentation des
prix de l'électricité je le rappelle je
pense que vous confondez les évaluations
de la creux qui est date de septembre
qui ont d'ailleurs baissé depuis sur
quel serait le tarif réglementé sur la
formule habituelle où effectivement la
présidente avait évalué en septembre
mais ça a baissé depuis entre 10 et 20 %
et le propos de Bruno leemire qui a été
constant et le mien aussi qui était pas
plus de 10 % puisque c'est comme ça qui
est structuré le bouclier électricité
c'est de fixer un plafond au prix de
l'électricité nous maintenons cette
protection en
2024 s'agissant de comment ça fonctionne
la redistribution bah c'est en fait on a
déjà vécu ça avec l'amorti et le
bouclier ça fonctionne sur la facture
c'est très simple et c'est automatique
merci beaucoup je vous propose de passer
au groupe Yot et c'est Benjamin saintuil
qui porte la parole de son
groupe merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre il y a beaucoup de
sujets qui ont déjà été abordés je vais
reprendre un sujet qui a été abordé par
la collègue btistel à laquelle vous avez
pas apporté de
réponse il y a un certain nombre des
voix qui s'élèv pour considérer que le
dispositif pourrait être considéré par
la Commission comme une aide d'État et
qui pourrait donc l'invalider j'aimerais
savoir ce qu'a prévu le gouvernement
dans cette situation euh pour essayer
d'y apporter une réponse de la même
manière et sans que ça soit une
provocation euh nous nous considérons
que la Commission pourrait être tentée
de demander en contrepartie de ce
dispositif euh une cission des activités
EDF pour libéraliser le marché ce qui
nous rappellerait euh des projets
Hercule plus ou moins HM j'aimerais
savoir quel est quel est votre regard en
la matière puisque ça fait partie des
éléments d'interrogation vous avez cité
les les trois axes qui ont conduit à à
l'accord européen décorréler le prix du
gaz électricité stabiliser le prix
deélec et sécuriser l'approvisionnement
sur la stabilisation du prix
d'électricité j' j'avoue de bonne fois
mais c'est sans doute lié à à ma propre
expérience euh ne pas tout à fait
comprendre les garanties qui sont les
nôtres pour que nous soyons en situation
de considérer qu'il y a une forme de
stabilisation garantie du prix enfin
parce que nous avons beaucoup parlé de
ces sujets ces dernières semaines je
vais vous parler un instant de la fusion
IRSN
ASN pour vous demander concrètement si
vous avez évalué les gain de temps
projeté dans la nouvelle organisation
administrative indépendante puisque
après avoir entendu l'IRSN l'ISN à
plusieurs reprises il semblerait que les
doublons que les les les manquements
comme les moments de crise gestion de
crise tout ça nous amène à une nouvelle
autorité indépendante administrative bon
il n dem pas moins que l'histoire de
cette fusion ce rapprochement c'est
d'abord la loi d'accélération du
nucléaire et du coup j'ai tendance à
penser que c'est la perspective
d'accélération des procédures qui vous
conduit à à prendre cette décision
j'aimerais savoir si vous avez évalué le
temps d'accélération et comment vous
pouvez nous garantir que cela ne se fera
pas au détriment ni de la transparence
ni évidemment de l'exigence de sécurité
que nous portons tous de manière très
élevée pour accompagner la filière je
vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
ministre alors peut-être pour vous
répondre le dispositif ne comporte pas
de dett d'État on ne fait que prendre et
redistribuer s'il y avait un plancher de
prix qui était garanti à EDF ça serait
une aide d'État mais dans la mesure où
il y a pas de plancher de prix ce n'est
pas une aide
d'État par contre effectivement il faut
que les contrats que mettent en place DF
c'est la manière dont il travaille sa
Comé sa politique commerciale permettre
la transparence et la réplicabilité et
ça c'est à EDF de mettre en place les
éléments qui permettent cela il y a un
travail de DF et il y a le gendarme de
la creux qui regarde et effectivement la
Commission européenne serait tout à fait
fondée de nous interroger de nous
demander de la transparence et des
garanties sur cette sur cet élément- là
mais ce n'est pas un sujet de dette
d'État sur la question de euh
oui c'est c'est autant une aide à EDF
que l'impôt sur le revenu est une aide
au contribuable si vous voulez hein le
système qu'on met en place comme ça je
pense que ça vous parlera c'est une
jolie c'est une jolie métaphore vous
l'avez compris que m'a transmise mon
directeur de cabinet
adjoint sur sur l'ASN et et l'IRSN oui
effectivement il y a des gains de temps
vous étiez avec moi hier dans cette
réunion un éliu mentionné que sur la
corrosion sous contrainte à
civo on a enfin c'est lui qui le raconé
hein gagné TR enfin perdu 3 à 4 mois
dans la reconnexion de la centrale au
réseau du réacteur au réseau pour des
raisons de processus entre l'ASN et
l'IRSN ce type effectivement de
situation qui n'est pas je dirais qu'il
a une logique d'interface entre deux
institutions qui doivent se renvoyer la
balle en rythme est effectivement un
problème c'est à fororie un problème pas
quand on veut aller plus vite mais tout
simplement quand on a plus de dossiers à
traiter merci beaucoup je vous propose
de passer aux questions individuelles
j'ai monsieur bertrambx Monsieur Charles
Gourson madame Julie larnous madame Ann
Laurence péel Maxime Lenet William
Martinet Dominique potier si d'autres
souhaitent intervenir on va vous noter
tout de suite on commence tout de suite
avec Bertrand
BX ça va all mieux mett en micro merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
vous avez eu l'occasion il y a quelques
années de vous rendre sur mon territoire
le Calvados pour y constater combien
l'industrie était présente et dans ce
cadre je souhaiterais savoir comment
l'accord qui a été négocié au niveau
européen va pouvoir profiter aux
industriels sur le prix de l'électricité
et notamment comment ils pourront être
compétitif face à des industriels
étrangers voire des voisins merci merci
beaucoup Monsieur Charles Courson
oui madame la ministre est-ce que pour
pourz nous faire le point sur comment on
va financer les 150 à 200 milliards
d'investissement du groupe EDF
c'està-dire les 50 milliards pour la
prolongation de 20 ans des réacteurs
existants les 50 milliards pour les 6 pr
en espérant que le coût ne doublera pas
et on dit 50 de certains 10 80 sur les
réseaux et quelle évolution des prix de
l'électricité envisagez-vous pour faire
face à ces besoins considérables sur la
fusion ASN
IRSN vous évoquez l'intérêt de fusionner
ces deux institutions pour accélérer les
délais mais il y a une convention entre
l'ISN et l'ASN et et et qui fixe des
délais et qui ont été toujours respectés
pour ce qui concerne l'IRSN et enfin
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il est bon que
la recherche reste dans une institution
unique alors que ça serait le seul cas
au monde toutes les ares institutions
soustraitep merci beaucoup madame Julie
larnous madame Julie larnous oui merci
monsieur le Président je vous confirme
madame la ministre que je n'ai jamais
été contacté par votre cabinet sur la
stratégie énergie climat c'est faux de
l'affirmer revenons aux annonces de
l'État et deedf sur le prix de
l'électricité beaucoup ont reproché à
juste titre au 42 € fixés de l'arine que
ça avit été fixé au doigts mouillés
aujourd'hui vous nous sortez 70 € du
mgawh qui semble être fixé de la même
manière pourquoi le prix de 110 € du
mgawh est choisi comme second seuil pour
le plafonnement de la rente le prix est
supérieur au prix nucléaire tel
qu'évalué par la creux pensez-vous que
ce soit aux Français de payer pour tout
pour rembourser la dette de DF et pour
financer la construction de nouvelles
centrales nucléaires sur les mécanismes
de redistribution ils sont quand même
extrêmement flous est-ce que vous pouvez
assurer que ça va bénéficier
principalement au plus précaair et pas
au plus gros consommateurs d'énergie et
euh je vous signale également pour avoir
discuté avec des fournisseurs qu' ne
savent aujourd'hui pas faire enfin la
consultation sur cet accord qui est
engagé avec les fournisseurs alternatifs
intervient après que vous ayez fait vos
annonces est-ce que leur avis vous
importe quelque peu ou est-ce que vous
avez déjà tout fixé à l'avance merci
Monsieur tibaau Bazin merci monsieur le
Président de nous redonner l'occasion
d'échanger madame la ministre je vous
remercie pour les premières réponses que
vous avez bien voulu pour être très
clair moi je suis opposé que vous non
mais que vous n avez transmise mais il
restait des questions dans mon
intervention et je voudrais préciser un
point parce que avec Sébastien Jumel on
s'était rassemblé pour justement
s'opposer au démantellement d' DF je
l'ai mentionné juste parce que à
l'époque ça avait été un des arguments
qui nous avaient été donnés que voilà et
je me rends compte que finalement à
travers la réforme on voit bien qu'on
peut y arriver non je je veux revenir
sur la question du du Turp qui va
potentiellement augmenter est-ce qu'on a
une idée de l'augmentation totale pour
le consommateur tur plus plus production
nucléaire de la facture finale à la
suite des mesures parce que vous bien
expliqué sur les premières questions
mais cette question là est très
importante pour les Français merci
beaucoup madame Laurence
péel merci monsieur le Président merci
madame la ministre je voudrais vous
parler de l'annonce de fusion ASN
IRSN au moment du projet de loi sur le
nucléaire plusieurs points de vigilance
avait été soulevé notamment sur la
publicité des avis et la transparence
des décisions sur l'indépendance des
branches expertise recherche avec celle
de la décision et la séparation
éventuelle de la recherche nucléaire
civil et militaire euh dans votre futur
projet de loi vous avez levé ces
inquiétudes qui subsistaient et je que
je viens lister en partie pourriez-vous
néanmoins nous préciser comment cette
fusion des deux des deux organisations
assurera-t-elle l'indépendance et
l'objectivité des chercheurs vis-à-vis
des preneurs de décision et deuxième
question comme j'ai pu le constater
auprès des divers acteurs de ma
circonscription les liens entre
nucléaire civil et militaires sont
essentiels le rattachement de la
recherche militaire au ministère des
armées euh
comment allez-vous mettre fin à cette
facilité de coopération comment
envisagez-vous de faire subsister cette
pollinisation entre ces deux ses merci
beaucoup monsieur Maxime Lenet merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
c'est une question à nouveau sur la
dissolution deirsn dans l'ASN c'est pas
la même qu'il a 15 jours en séance parce
que je redoute d'avoir la même non
réponse mais depuis il y a plusieurs
organismes qui se sont prononcés le
Conseil National de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche avec un
avis défavorable même chose pour le
Conseil supérieur de la fonction
publique d'État le Conseil national de
la transition écologique amis des
réserves même chose pour le Conseil
supérieur de l'énergie et euh le HC ISN
rendra son avis demain on s'attend
également un certain nombre de réserves
alors hier vous avez snobé la 35e
conférence des CIS qui se prononc
évidemment contre et la veille vous avez
annulé au dernier moment votre
déplacement pour rencontrer les salariés
de l'IRSN ce qui va leur laisser une
ardoise de plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'euros parce qu'ils avaient
quand même organisé l'événement ils ont
pris ça vraiment pour une marque de
mépris alors on voudrait braquer tous
les acteurs indispensables à cette
réorganisation qu'on s'y prendrait pas
autrement donc ma question est simple
que
cherchez-vous merci beaucoup nousons
avec William
Martinet merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre les français payent
de plus en plus cher pour pouvoir se
chauffer dans leur
logement bonjour madame la ministre je
disais excusez-nous c'était la question
on va remettre à zéro c'était la
question de Monsieur Len nous
interpeller c'est pour ça alle
question ou ouais moi j'étais surpris
par le prix qui était annoncé allez-y on
va en parler tout à l'heure c'est
intéressant allez-y monsieur Martini on
repart à zéro merci donc je disais les
français payent de plus en plus cher
pour pouvoir se chauffer dans leur
logement et c'est le cas notamment des
des Français qui se chauffe à
l'électricité et cette augmentation du
prix du chauffage elle a comme
conséquence qu'il y a de plus en plus de
Français qui souffrent du froid on a
doublé en l'espace de 2 ans la
proportion de Français qui a froid dans
son logement on est maintenant à 26 % et
moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est pas
seulement la situation actuelle mais
c'est que je ne vois rien dans vos
orientations politiques qui permet
d'endiguer cette spirale de la précarité
que ce soit l'accord avec EDF mais qui
est finalement une augmentation des
tarifs de l'électricité de 70 % que ce
soit la réforme du marché européen de
l'électricité mais dont je ne vois pas
en quoi elle remet en cause la capacité
des multinationales de l'énergie de
faire des super profits dans tous les
cas je vois un horizon de précarité
énergétique alors madame la ministre
est-ce que vous pouvez me dire
concrètement dans les mesures que vous
souhaitez prendre qu'est-ce qui va faire
que les Français arriveront à se
chauffer un peu mieux et n'auront pas
froid cette hiver merci merci beaucoup
monsieur
potier merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre on a fait une loi
d'accélération sur les énergies
renouvelables orors 9 mois après 10 mois
après on a encore on est encore à la
peine sur les décrets concernant
l'agrivoltaïsme et les processus servant
à définir les les les les zones
d'accélération sont toujours à la peine
dans les préfectures je le dis parce
queavec Eric botorel nous avions trouvé
un compromis entre le groupe socialiste
la majorité pour redonner des principes
clairs au déploiement de l'énergie
photovoltaïque sur les terres en
protégeant les terres agricoles et notre
souverereineté alimentaire et on avait
également défendu le principe d'une
planification fondée sur les
intercommunalités et le dialogue entre
les interc et le préfet ça a été le
fruit d'un compromis très difficile
parce qu'en CMP il a fallu composer avec
unee droite sénatoriale qui était pour
une planification communale c'est un peu
une sorte de de de d'hérésie dans dans
la terminologie aujourd'hui on constate
que nous avions mais tellement raison
qui c'est c'est les intercommunalités
qui en même temps que leur compétences
en économie en énergie et tout doivent
doivent piloter ces choses-là est-ce que
la loi de souveraineté que vous annoncez
permettra de récupérer le caractère
grbouille de ce que nous avons fait
contre notre gré à ce moment-là et enfin
de créer des instruments de
planification qu' forme à tout ce que
nous faisons dans nos territoires en
matière développement mer beauou merci
beaucoup j'ai pas vu le chrono passer
monsieur Marchive
oui merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre bon j'avais
deux questions la première concernant
l'accompagnement assez exceptionnel que
l'État avait pu mettre en place he suite
à la crise qu'on a pu connaître et en
particulier concernant un dispositif qui
a fait ses preuves qui est l'amortisseur
électricité il a fait ses preuves
notamment pour les collectivités pour
les
entreprises la question est savoir si
celui-ci il est prévu de le prolonger
dans les années à venir et une deuxième
question vous en avez déjà un petit peu
parl concernant les discussions qui
avaient été lancées à l'initiative de la
France et à l'échelle européenne pour
faire face à ce
dysfonctionnement qui est qui consistait
en l'alignement des prix de
l'électricité et du gaz sujet qui a été
mis sur la table sujet assez compliqué
ça a été évoqué par le président en
début de commission notamment avec avec
l'Allemagne pouvez-vous nous en dire
plus sur l'état d'avancement de ces
discussions je vous remercie merci
beaucoup che monsieur Sébastien
Jumel madame la ministre tout à l'heure
vous avez fait un peu une pirhouette sur
la question de de du monopole
d'exploitation de de DF je vous
interrogeais pas sur sur les Zr je vous
interrogais sur les
smmr le président de la Commission a
pris soin de dire qu' en état du droit
laasn n'avait pas le choix que nous nous
répondre ce qui nous répondait mais enin
la loi c'est c'est vous qui la fait vous
c'est le gouvernement en est à
l'initiative en lien avec le Parlement
mais vous avez quand même prévu un
projet plurannuel sur l'énergie une loi
de programmation sur l'énergie est-ce
que vous envisagez à la faveur d'une
vision globale et cohérente et
stratégique sur la relance du mix
énergétique de réaffirmer le monopole de
DF sur les SMR c'est c'est simple bien
sûr que c'est nous qui faisons la loi
mais le gouvernement peut avoir un avis
sur la nature de la loi ou je je je
complètement déconnecté non non mais
juste ça faisait sursauter monsieur de
courourson et moi-même quand vous avez
dit c'est vous qui faites la loi sinon
c'est quand même le législateur monsieur
Jumel
voilà merci Monsieur Jumel nous
continuons avec Marie Noël
btistel oui merci monsieur le Président
juste pour compléter sur la question du
décret notamment de sa sortie peut-être
tardive où on a un certain nombre de
projets qui sont finalement entre deux
réglementations et qui sont un peu en
standby dans les préfectures euh sur le
développement des EnR et notamment les
projets de enfin c'est ce que c'est ce
qu'on nous fait remonter sur le
photovoltaïque notamment et la question
euh également du seuil de de l'hydro où
vous avez été sollicité par beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'acteurs et où le CSE
a voté pour une diminution du seuil quel
quel en sera votre retour et que
comptez-vous
faire merci Monsieur Armand merci
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
merci merci d'être à nouveau à nouveau
devant nous ma question sans surprise
porte sur la sur la loi que que le
projet de loi que que vous présenterez
d'ici peu et et dans le sillage à la
fois de la commission d'enquête sur la
souveraineté énergétique que j'ai eu
l'honneur de rapporter sur les groupes
de travail dans les groupes de travail
il y a groupes et travail que vous avez
bien voulu animer pour vous demander
quels en seront les principales Ori
orientation et pour vous demander si la
souveraineté sera bien au cœur de ce
projet de loi je pense que d'abord c'est
indispensable politiquement parce que
c'est un point de consensus majeur entre
la plupart des groupes politiques
présents ici d'autre part parce que
c'est quand on pose la souveraineté
qu'on sort des postures entre sobriété
et production nous aurons besoin d'être
beaucoup plus sobre et de produire
beaucoup plus d'énergie décarboné et
c'est aussi quand on parle de
souveraineté qu'on sort des posture
libérale versus communiste sur le marché
de l'électricité puisque nous avons
besoin qu'aujourd'hui et demain les
entreprises cofinancent le nucléaire et
l'électricité pour être davantage
souverain en France merci beaucoup
j'ajouterai une dernière question de ma
part euh madame la minice et c'est
monsieur léné qui me l'a qui me l'a fait
évoquer vous avez parlé de plusieurs
milliers d'euros pour pas dire dizaines
de milliers d'euros sur une réunion qui
aurait été organisée par l'IRSN donc ma
question est de dire ma question est
très simple quel a été le coût de
réservation de cette réunion pourquoi et
sur quel marché ça a été pris et et et
qu'est-ce qui justifie un tel un tel
coût pour leur organisation d'une
réunion par un institut je vous
remercie00
personnel euh alors monsieur lénet je ne
sais pas comment vous avez l'avis du
CNTE ça m'étonne parce qu'il est en
train de se déroulé nous l'avons même
quitté avec Madame Laer noes et il
n'était pas terminé dans cette audition
donc je pense que vous présumer un peu
des forces du CNTE si je puis me
permettre et si effectivement euh et et
s'agissant des autres mentions c'est pas
tout à fait ce que vous indiquez
notamment la fonction publique regarde
l'aspect statutaire de la fonction
publique pas l'aspect réforme de la
Sûreté Nucléaire je n'ai par ailleurs
pas Somé snobé la CLI je devais
représenter le président de la
République World nuclear
exhibition avec le commissaire breton le
ministre tchck le ministre roumain et
j'ai réuni hier les présidents de C pour
de 20h à 22h pour faire un point sur le
projet de loi nucléaire certains d'entre
vous étaient d'ailleurs présents et
peuvent le confirmer Laurence PEL
malalement sainthuile les salariés je
les verrai la semaine prochaine et vous
avez raison nous organiserons nous-mêmes
la Réunion pour qu'elle ne coûte pas
140000 €. voilà c'est je ne sais pas
c'est pas moi qui l'a organisé c'est
l'IRSN chacun ses process mais on notera
que il y a peut-être moyen de le faire
plus
sobrement voilà et Guillaume aura le
détail euh
sur monsieur martinet je ne sais pas
d'où vous sortez ce chiffre
d'augmentation de 70 % mais
effectivement faut pas confondre 42 €
sur une une partie de la production
nucléaire et un prix moyen de 70 € sur
tout le nucléaire c'est juste la très
grosse différence pour vous donner une
idée aujourd'hui la composante
électricité du prix que payent les
ménages en électricité est de 110 € 110
€. ça c'est le TRV gelé aujourd'hui le
plafonnement du prix le bouclier la
composante électricité c'est 110 € ça
permet d'ailleurs de mettre un petit peu
les chiffres en perspective par rapport
au niveau que nous avons indiqué par
ailleurs que fait le gouvernement pour
permettre aux Français de passer l'hiver
et ben il prend 37 % de la facture en
charge ça s'appelle le bouclier
électricité et nous le prolongeons
l'année prochaine de manière à ce que la
facture n'augmente pas de plus de 10 %.
s'agissant
de Monsieur des zones d'accélération je
je je je reconnais que les EPCI sont
très mobilisés je les remercie dans ce
travail
de planification énergétique je précise
plusieurs choses un il y a pas besoin de
décret sur la partie définition des
zones d'accélération ça suppose pas de
décret ça c'est pour peut-être Marie
Laurence baptistel ce qui suppose un
décret c'est l'agro laagri
photovoltaïsme et je peux faire une
réponse commune ce décret je le je
présente entrer demain avec le président
des des chambres d'agriculture les
travaux qui ont été faits par ces mêmes
chambres pour donner un guide de mise en
œuvre de laagri voltaïsme dans les
territoires qui comporte un certain
nombre effectivement de recommandations
qui sont faites département par
département et qui seront ensuite mis en
œuvre département par département de
manière spécifique contenu de la
spécificité de chaque département et le
décret lui-même est transmis au Conseil
d'État dans les prochains jours avec une
un objectif de publication en début
d'année début d'année janvier euh
s'agissant du de la conduite de cette
planification elle est en cours hein je
je précise que les premières décisions
de zone d'accélération sont
effectivement prises par les communes
mais vous avez raison de souligner en
creux que les communes ne sont pas
toujours armé en ingénierie en effectif
au sein de leur commune pour mener cet
exercice difficile que nous moi j'ai
sollicité cité intercommunalité de
France pour aider donner un coup de main
aux communes qui sont dans une
intercommunalité et que vous savez que
c'est une discussion assez longue sur
lequel le Parlement a tranché peut-être
son choix aurait été différent quelques
mois après les sénatoriales plutôt que
quelques mois avant les sénatoriales
mais les parlementaires ont tranché je
respecte cette décision
s'agissant de est-ce que la loi peut
faire la loi peut le défaire mais ça je
ne vous apprends rien euh monsieur euh
Marchive sur l'amortisseur c'est
effectivement une question sur lequel on
doit donner la visibilité euh aux
entreprises pour l'année prochaine nous
allons prolonger la garantie
280 sur euh l'ensemble des des contrats
souscrits le guich le bouclier euh
énergétique donc pardon l'amortisseur il
est prolongé sur 75 % de l'écart du coût
de
l'électricité au-delà de ces 250 € de
mémoir euh et il permettra justement de
prendre en charge les contrats qui ont
été conclus au moment où la le prix de
l'électricité était au plus haut
c'est-à-dire jusqu'au 30 30 juin 2023
tous ces contrats qui pour certains se
prolongent en 2024 parfois jusqu'en 2025
nous allons les traiter maintenant et
nous allons les traiter en faisant sorte
que le surplomb que nous constatons par
rapport à 350 € pardon sera pris en
charge à 75 % et sans plafond puisque
certains se voyaient imposer un plafond
de la de 500 € là il n'y aura pas de
plafond donc c'est une
véritable véritable effort du
gouvernement pour j'allais dire nettoyer
la situation finale que nous constatons
sur les dernières entreprises qui ont
encore des contrats très difficiles pour
les années 24 et parfois malheureusement
25 bien entendu j'en profite le bouclier
collectif pour les collectivités les les
logements collectifs sera également
prolongé bien pas d'autrre remarqu
madame la ministre c'est
bon alors je vois des députés dis a pas
répondu mais si elle a été très complète
madame la ministre sur sa réponse ce non
je suis pas allé jusqu'à monsieur qu' a
une frustration tout à fait évidente et
monsieur de Courson où est-ce que je
vous ai noté monsieur de Courson
pourtant j'ai noté là ah ben voilà j'ai
j'ai sauté une feuille pardon vous avez
parfaitement raison donc monsieur Bou
monsieur boui accord européen sur le
prix de l'électricité qu'est-ce qui
prouve que ça sera compétitif pour les
industriels et bien cet accord européen
il permet trois choses la première chose
c'est d'obliger le marché européen donc
la même chose que ce que nous faisons en
France de donner des signaux de long
terme et d'avoir de la maturité plus les
les contrats peuvent être conclus sur du
5 ans plus on enlève de la volatilité au
prix et on enlève l'impact d'une
augmentation ponctuelle des coûts de
telle ou telle énergie fossile du fait
d'une situation qui se passe à l'autre
bout du monde une raffinerie qui qui
brûle ou quoi qui est sur le prix de
l'électricité et ça permet de
reconverger vers la réalité des coûts de
production en tout cas c'est l'objectif
ça donne de la visibilité aux
producteurs ça donne de la visibilité
aux industriels dans leur processus de
décarbonation et de donc de passage à
électrification c'est ça qui est
derrière l'enjeu et par ailleurs nous
renforçons les clauses de protection du
consommateur notamment en imposant aux
fournisseurs d'électricité soit d'être
adossé sur la production physique soit
de prendre des engagements prudentiels
pour être capable de livrer les volumes
qu'il euh s'engageent à livré euh
monsieur de Courson la couverture les 70
€ ça couvre le carénage et le nouveau
nucléaire ça ne couvre pas les réseaux
qui a un système spécifique de
financement qui est le Turp et pour
faire le lien à une autre question le
Turp monsieur Bazin il a vocation dans
les années qui viennent à évoluer grosso
modo rythme de
l'inflation je parle d'une inflation
classique pas d'une inflation en période
de haute
inflation 1 2 % c'est pas tout à fait
classique mais 2 % on va dire enfin dans
ces eaul sur
euh le et donc le prix de 70 € c'est un
prix tout compris qui représente la
réalité des coûts de du nucléaire
français et qui permettent lorsqu'ils
sont délivrés de ne pas augmenter la
dette deedf cette dette deedf qui est
notamment lié au fait que EDF a livré
aux consommateurs et nous en avons tous
bénéficié de l'électricité très bon
marché à un moment où d'autres d'autres
producteurs d'énergie dans d'autres pays
ont pu eux profiter de cette manne
bienfaisante et se désendetter la
convention que vous mentionnez entre
l'ASN et l'IRSN vous avez tout à fait
raison de la mentionn elle est négociée
tous les 5 ans et elle est négociée
c'est une négociation elle fait l'objet
de neuf accords cadres sur un certain
nombre d'activités et donc il faut la
revoir tous les 5 ans et tous les ans il
y a une nouvelle négociation qui
intervient
pour prévoir la l'allocation prioritaire
des ressources et des moyens pour
l'instruction des priorités donc vous
voyez bien que dans un exercice où
grosso modo on continue ce qu'on a fait
d'une année sur l'autre c'est un système
qui fonctionne dans un système où au
contraire la charge de travail évolue
avec des surprises dans les dossiers tel
dossier qui accélère tel dossier qui
ralentit ce serait une négociation
permanente ce que nous proposons c'est
que comme cela se fait d'ailleurs assez
naturellement tous les gens qui sont
chargés de la même mission sont au sein
d'une entité unique et et ce processus
qui s'appelle juste gérer un processus
une mission de service public se fasse
en interne sur sur qui qui on met sur
tel et
tel priorité si ça change les délis
puisque ça vous permet de répondre
immédiatement et ne pas avoir ce
processus où il faut se recaler à chaque
fois qu'il y a une nouveauté et je le
redis sur la corrosion moi c'est encore
une chose une fois quelque chose qui m'a
été rapporté par des élus que j'ai
réunis hier avec certains d'entre vous
qui l'ont entendu également on me dit
que sur la la reconnexion d'un réacteur
en l'occurrence c'était celui de civo
qui était l'exemple cité he ça fait un
décalage de quelques mois du fait de
cette coordination qui n'est pas
parfaite mais ce qui est normal je
encore une fois c'est deux entités qui
ont chacune leur comité de direction qui
poursuivent chacune un intérêt social
alors qu'elles sont en fait au service
de la même mission et devrait être au
service du même intérêt social sur la la
viabilité économique des CMR je vais
répondre l'avenir nous le dira euh non
mais pardon nous sommes dans des
aujourd'hui à des stades euh de euh
comment dire d'innovation de recherche
de développement et d'innovation euh et
donc c'est la même chose pour un certain
nombre de technologies que nous
soutenons la pyogazéification je ne sais
pas vous dire si c'est compétitif mais
je le soutiens en innovation parce que
ça fait parti partie du rôle de l'État
que de dérisquer des projets de
recherche de développement et
d'innovation et de faire en sorte de
préparer l'avenir mais je peux vous le
dire sur des énergies renouvelable comme
sur des projets nucléaires on peut
penser que le projet nuvard est plus
avancé donc sa capacité à trouver un
équilibre économique est plus sécurisé
cont tenu de sa maturité plus avancée et
aussi du fait que c'est des
technologies moins de rupture que
d'autres d'autres projets sur Madame
laernoes la redistribution je vous
renvoie au document de concertation qui
explicite cette redistribution qui va
donc directement sur la facture du
consommateur et qui suit en cela la
réglementation de l'éleectricity market
design qui est une redistribution en
fonction de la du profil de consommation
dans la journée et de manière comment
dire linéaire puisque c'est ce que
prévoit
cette ce règlement pardon sur le tuc tuc
tuc la dette de DF je le redis cette
dette de DF elle est liée à l'activité
de DF aussi pour fournir le français
c'est ce prix du service public c'est
aussi ce prix de la difficulté à à à
produire ces dernières années et euh et
nous allons et c'est pour ça que nous
travaillons sur la performance
opérationnelle de DF enfin sur les
fournisseurs c'est évidemment une
discussion que nous avons hein la
tuyauterie la transparence la
réplicabilité les fournisseurs ont fait
un travail alternatif ont fait un
travail formidable l'année dernière pour
en 2 mois mettre en place l'amortisseur
et le bouclier énergétique là on a 2 ans
et effectivement nous prenons ce ce
travail à la fois de tuyauterie et de
non mais j'ai réuni les fournisseurs il
y a une semaine mardi pendant 2h donc
c'est effectivement ça fait partie des
sujets que nous avons abordé
euh monsieur Bazin le Turp je vous ai
répondu les 70 € je vous ai répondu
madame péel euh l'indépendance des
chercheurs alors je vous le redis péel
oui
euh l'indépendance des des chercheurs
dans la nouvelle organisation cette
indépendance elle est garantie par le
statut d'autorité administrative
indépendante et par le fait que la loi
lui conférera l'ensemble
des de tout ce qui permet de se
revendiquer organisme de recherche donc
non seulement le fait de le revendiquer
mais également toute la la capacité à
recruter tous les profils de
d'enseignant chercheurs d'étudiants
enfin voilà de de de chercheurs de
postdoc et cetera c'est un travail que
nous avons mené avec le Ministère de la
Recherche et et je veux dire quand ça on
va au-delà des
recommandations internationales en
matière de sûreté nucléaire
l'indépendance elle doit se faire
théoriquement ça c'est les
recommandations internationales
vis-à-vis des opérateurs nous ce que
nous faisons c'est que nous le faisons
vis-à-vis du gouvernement ce qui n'est
pas aujourd'hui le cas de l'IRSN puisque
l'IRSN est un épique c'est un
établissement public il n'a pas de
collège il n'a pas une gouvernance qui
lui Perm d'avoir cette indépendance en
étant qualifié d'autorité administrative
indépendante il trouve cette
indépendance pleine et entière non
seulement par rapport aux opérateurs ce
qui était déjà le cas mais également par
rapport au au gouvernement j'ajoute que
la déontologie de l'ISN historiquement
était d'une autorité administrative
indépendante en règle générale et est
suivie de très très près il y avait plus
de mouvement on va dire du côté de
l'IRSN et donc ça c'est aussi un sujet
d'indépendance qui qui est conforté et
nous traitons par contre le sujet de la
recherche avec des acteurs industriels
qui est un sujet très important que nous
allons maintenir effectivement avec des
règles déontologie qui permettront de
poursuivre ces recherches parce qu'elles
sont importantes alors lorsqu'elles sont
faites avec des acteurs internationales
c'est pas un problème puisquil y a pas
de relation de contrôle lorsque ce n'est
pas fait avec des acteurs
internationales il faut ce cadre de
déontologie sur lequel nous
travaillons là je crois que j'ai répondu
à tout le monde
et Monsieur Armand les Prin monsieur gu
monsieur monsieur Caspar monsieur Armand
oui vous avez raison ce projet de loi
nous le voulons pour la
souveraineté de l'énergie parce que
c'est ça qui est aujourd'hui en cause on
peut l'appeler programmation régulation
protection du consommateur mais
fondamentalement ce dont nous parlons
c'est d'affronter le mur énergétique qui
nous attend en 2030 en prenant les
décisions qui ne nous mettent pas dans
une situation d'iver énergétique et je
sais que vous y avez travaillé au
travers de la mission que vous avez
coporté avec raphaë Chelon berger en
transpartisan à nouveau et c'est de ça
que nous voulons aujourd'hui parler avec
le Parlement je sais que c'est un sujet
sur lequel l'assemblée national et le
Sénat sont très engagés et très attachés
et c'est comme ça c'est parce que nous
aurons ces quatre piliers de sobriété
d'efficacité d'énergie renouvelable et
de nucléaire que nous serons en capacité
d'assurer la souveraineté électrique et
énergétique de notre
pays très
bien c'est bon ouais très bien ben
écoutez merci beaucoup madame la
ministre pour vos propos et vos réponses
très complètes à nos questions et chers
collègues merci pour votre présence et
je vous souhaite donc une bonne fin
d'après-midi merci
beaucoup